no sooner had President Putin annexed
four regions in Ukraine then his troops
were forced to flee from a key City in
one of them and Russian tank defenses
were breached in another the humiliation
wasn't lost on Russian commanders with
the Chechen warlord ramzan khadirov
calling for Moscow to use tactical
nuclear weapons my guest this week from
Kiev is ihor javka Deputy head of the
presidential Administration has Ukraine
backed Mr Putin into a corner where he
might use his nuclear Arsenal you may
not have any other Battlefield
instruments to to withstand the
Ukrainian counter advances so I think
Ukraine is taking this seriously and the
International Community has to take it
seriously for now though what has
changed the fortunes of Ukraine's armed
forces and can they keep up the momentum
how do they treat suspected Ukrainian
collaborators and why is the door to
peace talks still firmly shut
[Music]
welcome to conflict Zone
thank you for having me
your forces have had a spectacular month
six thousand square kilometers seized
back from Russia you've just taken one
of their Key Supply hubs in donetskin
you've broken through in the south in
kerson how important are these latest
successes to you both on the battlefield
and psychologically
well uh thank you for this question
really it is very important on the
battlefield I mean uh if you take the
first days and months of War many in the
world didn't believe that Ukraine will
not be able only to even to withstand
the the war and then to have any major
success on the territory of uh my
country but throughout this more than
seven months of the war we we proven to
ourselves first of all and then to the
world community that we can not only
fight with the Russian aggression we can
withstand this Russian language we can
stop this Russian aggression in this
country but we can counter to have
counter advances and definitely we will
we will uh we will have all our
territories back so that is why it is
important that we have these counter
advances on numerous directions we have
very good advances on the area almost
all the region of harkive uh oblast is
is liberated by Ukrainian Armed Forces
really we have good advances in the
donors remember Russia wanted to capture
all the lugansk and Donetsk region
immediately from the beginning of this
open War because they were trying to
capture it from 2014 not any success is
happening for them on the donors candle
against region and the same you're right
here on the south around here soon uh
it's also uh our armed forces are
advancing it's it's more slowly than the
harkiv region but it's very important so
it's really a very important thing for
the armed forces and really right you
are morally moral it's important for our
people for each and every Ukrainian
citizens living in Ukraine or having to
leave Ukraine for a period of time uh
when the war is happening but all of US
presidents Ukrainian people Ukrainian
government uh you know helping each each
of us in our own manner to bring this
Victory and really what it's doing what
is done by an armed forces of Ukraine is
really at Mark not only Ukraine but I
think you know the world
what's brought about this stunning
change in your fortunes on the
battlefield and can you maintain the
momentum well first of all once again is
to the strength and Mastery of Ukrainian
Armed Forces but secondly this is due to
the equipment ammunition and weapons
which is coming in the more bigger
quantities from our Western Partners
most of the countries
to which we applied at the beginning of
War to bring us additional heavy
Weaponry additional artillery additional
tanks armored vehicles additional
multi-launch rocket systems are now
starting to help us and this is what
really shows and this is what really
helps to Our Success because you know
you cannot find only what they what they
with a gun you'll fight the Modern War
and you make the counter advances with
the modern Western Equipment yes we've
got some equipment inherited from the
Soviet Union but now we proved again to
us and to all of the world that ukrain
regular armed forces can Master the
model Western NATO equipment and we can
fight with it and we can win with it so
yes I think we will be able to get the
momentum it was very important for us to
start this counter Advance before the
winter time because Soviet is much more
easier to make counter the advances
during the uh the the the the the the uh
the time which efforts to do this in
winter time usually it's much easier to
fortify to defend so that's why our
Armed Forces will make everything
possible to to to gain this momentum and
to move forward how do you expect the
Kremlin to react to your advances I'm
assuming you don't expect Putin to
accept these defeats shrug his shoulders
and walk away
well I think well well well he hadn't
had been having absence of success on
the battlefield you know if his Armed
Forces uh definitely not the second
strongest army in the world as he
portrayed his Armed Forces probably he
had bad reports from his generals about
the strength of the Russian Armed Forces
but as a reaction to these success of
Ukrainian Armed Forces he probably you
know had to to to use this several
instruments one of them those sham
referendums which he orchestrated on the
part of the Ukrainian territory which is
now temporarily occupied so he's trying
to now to make an attempted annexations
another attempted annexation the same
way as he did it in 2014 that's why very
important now not to to repeat the
mistakes of 2014 with the world
Community the international partners of
Ukraine let me very honest overslept
these actions which Putin uh was doing
so really this is a very good time when
all the International Community reacted
negatively these same referenda and
these attempted annexation was in their
position and different formats at
different levels and that's helping
Ukraine to fight the Russian aggressor
isn't the danger that you push him into
a corner and force him to react he has
after all weapon systems that you don't
have I'm talking about nuclear weapons
how do you assess the chance of him
using at least Battlefield nuclear
weapons especially if you keep beating
him on the battlefield
well look this is not the first time in
during this open War when he blackmails
all of us not only Ukraine all the world
with a nuclear weapon or Airline
connected with a chemical and biological
weapon well I mean don't you take it
seriously don't you take it seriously
the threat yes we take it seriously we
take it seriously now because because
look
he has he may not have any other
Battlefield instruments to to withstand
the Ukrainian counter advances so I
think Ukraine is taking this seriously
and the International Community has to
take it seriously after all we have
several nuclear states in the world they
have to react they have to prevent him
from doing this they have to tell him
about the dire consequences if he even
dares to to to to to to to to to use it
partially on the battlefield or on some
remote areas these she should not he
should not even think about this so
that's my vice president when talking to
the world leaders he he asks them
Ukraine is a non-nuclear state we don't
have a nuclear uh weapons you remember
we we
give it away in 2000 in in 1994 on our
own Goodwill so that's why we need the
protection of the rest of the nuclear
powers to protect all the world not only
Ukraine not only Europe all the work
from using this uh nuclear weapon
According to some newspapers NATO is
said to have warned its members that
Russia may be about to Stage a nuclear
test or some other nuclear demonstration
as a warning to Ukraine and the West do
you give any Credence to these reports
well we believe to all the credible
information which our partners Western
Partners
provide to us and definitely did they
inform you about this
well definitely I think our security
forces and intelligence forces have to
be in contact with their relevant
partners and have to have this
information a defense analyst in Poland
has reported that a train operated by
Russia's nuclear division was bound for
Ukraine have you received such reports
well again I saw these news in the Press
I don't necessarily have this official
report and I don't think that something
which is leaked to the Press is a real
information but again we all should take
it seriously
and if you had had such a report would
you tell me
probably this is not the information I
should tell to the press all right your
president has promised you will liberate
all the territory that Russia has seized
does that include Crimea and tell me how
you can achieve that goal and at the
same time minimize the risk to the
civilian populations that are living
under occupation at the moment
look Crimea is Ukraine you remember the
format my present invented which is a
Crimean platform this year we had a
second stomach of Crimea platform in the
online format obviously 40 leaders
participated not only leaders of Europe
and your Atlantic area but leaders of
African countries Asian countries Latin
American countries and each and every of
them said Crimea as Ukraine and Ukraine
has all the rights to deliberate this
territory so answering your question yes
definitely when my president is speaking
about liberating all the territories of
Ukraine he means all the territories
really all the territories including the
Ukrainian Peninsula so in the borders as
of 24th of August
1991. the instruments might be different
uh so it's it's it's it's it's too
complicated now to tell how we will
Liberate the Crimea but definitely these
these this goal is on our Radars will we
be seeing more Guerrilla style attacks
by the underground units that you've
been training now for some time this
sort of homeless distance there have
been a lot of reports in the Press
talking to these members of your Armed
Forces do you believe that these groups
can make Russia pay such a high cost
over time that uh they will eventually
relinquish the land that they've taken
from you
well if you must make specifically about
Crimea we all notice that something
something not good for Russia is taking
place in the Crimea I don't know what is
the origin of this but definitely not
something good for Russia but but but
generally speaking look we have a rather
strong Armed Forces which you know what
no one can doubt historically Ukraine
has also has an experience of having the
Guerrilla Wars I think many of the world
has forgotten that Ukraine has know how
knows how to fight we are fighting with
Russia
throughout the centuries I mean for more
than 400 years Russia wanted to capture
Ukraine and try to capture Ukraine in
different formats be the formats of USSR
or the Russian Empire so ukrainians
having their blood the knowledge the The
Experience how to fight including these
this this this type of of of War which
you call Guerrilla War but the once
again look at what our armed forces are
doing I think with this Tempo with this
speed with this support of International
Community we're enjoying I think uh the
weeks the victory is more and more near
obviously Russian troops are your
primary targets do you also regard
Russia's civilian administrators those
who've been drafted into the so-called
annexed areas do you regard them as
legitimate targets as well look we are
civilized country we're not we do not
fight with civilians it's Russia who
fights when when Finland failing to
conquer the Ukrainian soldiers they try
to not only try they are doing day and
night uh bombing civilian objects
civilian targets and civilian people we
are fighting with the attorney and the
enemies there are armed forces of Russia
if you are if you are asking me about
those uh those still ukrainians who are
for instance you know cooperating with
the occupation Powers we have in other
instruments we have another instrument
so the first instruments are being
sanctions and by the way thank you for
the International Community it was
already preparing the sanctions for
those who were agonizing those same
referendums but the second is after we
win the war each and every who was
cooperating with the occupational
authorities who was killed in Ukrainian
Soldier and civilians will be will be
punished will have his or her own way of
responsibility that's why my president
is now arguing about creating an
international Tribunal for the for the
for the for the Russians who are
responsible for killing Ukrainian
sojournal civilians that is why we are
bringing this issue to the United
Nations we are bringing this issue to
our International Partners I think this
will be the best possible way to punish
them and what about reports of that
there's been summary Justice for some of
your own civilians the New York Times
report in August said your special
partisan units were killing those
ukrainians who were deemed to be
collaborating with the Russians is that
true I know I can I cannot command uh
this to you I do not have this
information almost 2 000 ukrainians now
face charges of having come implied with
the demands of Russian Invaders or
occupiers they could get up to 15 years
in jail how certain can you be that
they'll get a fair trial under the
current circumstances uh definitely we
will have a fair trial I mean look I
will give you a very very very Vivid
example you know when we liberated the
areas of Northern Ukraine which is
Butcher gustome we found an Evidence of
many atrocities made by Russian Armed
Forces when killing raping you know
children women and men and we brought
International inspectors from the
international criminal court from our
partner countries forensic experts
detectives and they are you know were
sickened for each and every evidence of
these Collective crime but the crime is
collective but the concrete persons who
are responsible for the crime they're
individuals and this is not only
President Putin who gives the general
orders there's a dictionary General each
and every major each and every so
soldier who is responsible so believe me
we will be very scrupulous again with
the support and help of our partners and
we will bring each and every person to
the Justice which he or she deserves
collaboration is is difficult to prove
isn't it Mr javka because how do you
distinguish between those who were
forced at the point of a gun to comply
with orders or physically abused or
whose relatives were threatened from
people who wanted to help the Russians
these are very tricky cases aren't they
it's a very tricky cases but I don't
think we have the first ever historical
example of collaboration we will
definitely use the historic experience
believe me everyone who is now
collaborating on his or her own will
will be punished
Putin's threats and denunciations last
week was a a direct call for you to end
the hostilities and talk peace we're
ready for this Mr Putin said how do you
see that offer you know from the
beginning of this open War and my my my
might saw this numerous appeals and
speeches and reports and whatever and my
president was ready for negotiations my
president even created a a team who was
negotiating with Russian team and you
remember there were several meetings uh
but we were ready for the negotiations
for the for the fruitful negotiations
not for the negotiations of the Russian
conditions and you remember on some
point of time Russians even started to
listen to Ukrainian delegation and even
took you know the draft proposals of
Ukraine then out of a sudden out of a
sudden they returned to our their
previous position you can only negotiate
with Russia and Russian conditions you
can only negotiate on Russian redlines
you can only Associated Russian
ultimatums so when now we have the
narrative or hear The Narrative of
President Putin himself or his cronies
that Russia is ready if Russia were
ready to negotiations Russia would not
have the same referendums because you
might remember the words of my president
back in March or April if Russia dares
to make this sham referendums there is
nothing to talk to Russia so tell me now
what is to talk with us if Russia
captures illegally trying to Annex four
additional areas of Ukraine what is the
subject of negotiations
but hasn't your own president set out
his own peace formula
um that you know in advance the Russians
aren't going to accept and will never
accept I mean he laid out Five Points
didn't he among them punishment for
Russia's aggression and restoration of
security and territorial Integrity I'm
ruling out a settlement he said that
isn't based on the Ukrainian peace
formula so it's this way or no way is
isn't that the position isn't your that
your position well this was a peace
formula but look where it was you know
outer it was really you know outspoken
in the united National General Assembly
Tribune really this is a peace formula
right you are the peace formula
president Ukraine but the peace formula
for the whole world we have our own
experience so we do share it with
International Community look what is
happening of Ukraine look what should
not happen here in each and every
country anymore because when the
aggressor feels he will not be punished
later on because there is no illegal
instrument because event is not doing
the punishment there is no you know a
world policeman can do this punishment
so in order this to have not to happen
My President is sharing his formula of
peace right you are any more ends with
negotiations so sooner or later these
are that kind of negotiations will have
to happen and we will be ready to settle
down the the the conditions of victory
of Ukraine but in this case negotiations
should be resentful negotiations should
bring together our partners together
probably uh with Ukraine and that's why
my president is telling about security
guarantees after the war you know that
this aggression not to happen anymore
because Russia unfortunately when we
expect will be always aggressive so we
together now should think how this not
only to end this aggression to bring the
war to an end but how make this
aggression not happen in the future or
if it happens
to have the legal guarantees of which
country does what in order to secure
peace in this part of the world but for
the moment the the daughter peace talks
is firmly shut isn't it for the time
being the only talks could be on the
battlefield
let's talk about the issue if we may
have
Ukraine and NATO which has been there
for many years and never goes away NATO
membership in in August you criticized
the alliance for not giving you any what
you call solid Prospect of membership
despite your Army's increasing
compatibility with NATO troops and
systems we know that NATO leaders are
dodging the question in public of your
membership what are they telling you
behind the scenes are they more
optimistic about that in private
well you saw that on Friday by President
someone an application for for for NATO
membership and asked the the NATO
members to to be to be thinking about
this already now he didn't get much of a
reply did he he didn't get much of a
reply well why not why not uh on October
2nd we had the statement of night
president of central European countries
that they are absolutely welcome in the
decision of Bucharest Summit in 2008 I
have to remind you the Bucharest Summit
2008 was very clearly Ukraine should
become a member of NATO and the first
instrument should be membership action
plan what is happening now we see that
after Russia's open aggression many
things changed it was Sweden and Finland
they are almost entering NATO several
protocols have to be ratified but they
are entry native without membership
action plan so Ukraine is telling okay
we took notice of this we are now
fighting the war we are enjoying the
support and help of NATO allies all of
them bring us Weaponry all of them
helping us with sanctions all of them
bring us financial assistance but look
it's high time now to think what will
happen after the war that's why my
president is telling yes let's think
about possible entering your Ukraine to
Nato well or now let's all of you think
about security guarantees for Ukraine at
this period of time so we are suggesting
vast option of choices and our partners
no one said no I didn't say I didn't
hear clear no say no Ukraine will never
become a member of NATO the same is no
one says but you didn't hear it yes
either did you you didn't hear a yes
either definitely NATO wasn't the
consensus principle no one says that
consensus discontentions will happen
tomorrow but we should work on this now
Ukraine puts the purposes to NATO allies
and I think all each and everything
should think what to do next as part of
peace settlement would you ever agree
not to join NATO
no
that's out of the question is it
yes
Mr javco what if in the end of this war
you can't achieve outright Victory and
the best you can get is not to lose
would you settle for that right now with
the country settle for that
you know I like the DVD Visa stance
which is expressed almost by all leaders
of of the world who are speaking to my
president it's only Ukraine and only
Ukraine who will Define this scope of
Victory what will mean victory for
Ukraine and when you hear the narratives
that someone is you know inclined in
Ukraine or this or that you know
conditions or whatever don't believe
them believe me it's very hard you know
to make president zielinsky to go to any
you know surrenders or to meet any
conditions which are not coinciding with
the national interests of Ukraine we
will fight we will fight to the end and
the endless victory of Ukraine
unfortunately no one will tell you now
when will be this Victory and how many
lives still to be sacrificed but again
we deserve throughout this seven months
of War that's only ukrainians Ukrainian
president Ukrainian people Ukrainian
Armed Forces who will decide uh what is
the scope of Ukrainian Victory you
talked about about thinking ahead to the
end of the war do you foresee having to
remain a heavy militarized State for the
foreseeable future with security a
constant priority always on your guard
are you are you ready for that kind of
future
yes yes yes uh I think you're putting it
rightly uh the situation will never be
the same in Ukraine and around Ukraine
uh you know many tell about the the the
the common association with some other
countries in the world but look Ukraine
has its own destiny unfortunately yes
and fortunately for us that after this
war after this Victory Ukrainian Armed
Forces will be ever stronger even a
mighty more experience more skillful
knowing how to fight with the modern
equipment
here into NATO standards by the way you
know when when no one no one will tell
you now or tell us now that you are not
interoperable with with with NATO uh
armed forces or whatever we are more
than interoperable we are fighting now
again definitely not with the second
strongest army in the world but
definitely not with the weakest army in
the world so yes at this experience this
experience we are ready to share we are
ready to be this Forefront of the whole
European continent where destined to be
here we will not transfer Ukraine
somewhere to to another part of the
world so yes uh probably this will be
the case for Ukraine very briefly some
experts in the west have suggested that
what we're witnessing with the conflict
in Ukraine is the start of the third
world war third world war between Russia
and the West is that how you see this
conflict no this is how Putin sees this
conflict in his narrative he is already
fighting not only with uh with the whole
West not only with NATO you know but
probably with the most part of the world
except some countries who you know who's
supporting him no this is false Russian
narratives and probably this would be a
visual thinking of Russia we are
fighting with Russia we are fighting
Russian aggressor it's not Ukraine who
started the words Russia we started the
world in 2014 then it started the open
phase in 2022 we are fighting by our own
we don't have Goods on the ground our
armed forces are fighting yes but the
support of modern equipment weapons Etc
but we are destined to fight alone and
we're destined to win this war
it's been a pleasure to have you once
conflict Zone thank you very much indeed
for your time thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]